مساعدات عسكريه قدرت بمليارات الدولارات
قدمتها اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بموافقه الى الحزبين في الكونغرس الا ان
استمرار هذه المساعدات بات على المحج في
حال استعاده الجمهوريين السيطره الكامله
على الكونجرس في انتخابات التجديد النصفيه
خصوصا بعد التصريحات التي اثارتها النائبه
الجمهوريه في تجمع
وفقا لتقرير نشرته واشنطن بوست جرين قالت
انه في حال سيطره الجمهوريين على الكونغرس
واحد اخر الى اوكرانيا لان الولايات
المتحده تاتي اولا على حد وصفها هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي يدلي فيها جمهوريون
تصريحات تتعلق باوكرانيا فقبل ايام من خرج
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
كيف بتصريحات شديده اللهجه موجهه للقاده
قال فيها انه يجب على اوكرانيا تتوقع
الدعم والمساعدات في حال نجاح الحزب
الجمهوري بالفوز بالاغلبيه في الكونغرس
وفي المقابلي وعلى اثر هذه التصريحات
الحاده جاء انتقاد مستشار السياسه
الخارجيه السابق لبراك اوباما على تصريحات
مكارت عبر تويتر واصفا هذه التصريحات التي
جاءت في اوجي اخطر حرب في اوروبا منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
في ان يكون رئيسا لمجلس النواب
الحزب الديمقراطي الذي ينظر الى المساعدات
التي تقدمها واشنطن لكي يفعل انها مساعده
من اجل مستقبل الديمقراطيه والنظام
الليبرالي نفسه والذي يضغط على
الاوكرانيين في نفس الوقت للتخلي عن رفضهم
الدخول في حوار مع الكرم يرى ان انتخابات
التجديد النصفيه في الولايات المتحده هي
تصويت على استمرار الدعم لاوكرانيا وهو
الامر الذي زاد من شده قلق المسؤولين
الاخرانيين بعد التهديدات الاخيره من جانب
كبار المشرعين الجمهوريين الامري بقطع
المساعدات عن اوكرانيا وذلك في حال سيطره
الجمهوريين على الكونجرس الامريكي في
انتخابات التجديد النصفي سلطان العيبان
العربيه